the raven was part of the croatian story
in our culture he put me out here on the
tundra that i love so much
we were put here by our creator
this is the story of how we lived
and how we survived
for thousands of years
it's a ball
i gotta shoot high
i saw blood
let's go get him
my name is jody potts
i'm hong guichen of the raven clan
masichu
i feel a lot of gratitude to creator for
allowing me to be indigenous to the land
and having the blessing of living this
life here with my kids and my husband
we point the moose's head towards home
to honor the moose
towards the direction of our home where
it's going to feed our family and our
village
indigenous peoples of alaska we're still
here we're still maintaining our culture
and our way of life and we're fighting
for it
generation after generation
[Music]
during my time of growing up there
wasn't really no teaching you know you
learned from a hand-drawn you didn't
read a book on our native way
somebody gave him some gas
i'm gonna go on an adventure up to all
the bay and set the king crab pot
on this beautiful day calm before the
storm
i'm marvin agnot from the village of
akyok
i grew up here pretty much all my life
which is a little over half a century
a luthic is what i am
today we're on a mission to go and get
some food for the winter
but it's very windy and we got a storm
coming and we got to work pretty quick
we got to go miles away just to hope we
could get king crab because
overfishing that alone really hurt us
because our way of living is on the
water
akiaki is very unique
because of its remoteness we are limited
to our resources because of
accessibility
we got to work harder to get more to
make ends meet
but regardless we make it work out here
[Music]
rain snow
wind we'll go on dinner seafood
when the tide is low the table is set
it roars through here very fast when a
tide comes through
i have to get the pot dropped before the
storm coming
the weather changes so quick and
it's an hour skip ride one way and
within that hour it can be blowing 50
miles an hour
it becomes disastrous for us
when we do get it it is worth the effort
that we put into it
we are way out in the middle of no man's
land
i just found out over years that
it's a lot easier to get crab up in this
area than it is out in the lower bay
because of how big and vast it is
it is very dangerous because this bay
freezes up in the winter it's just a
matter of when it'll happen
we have to pull this up before the
freeze
right well i beat the
storm that's coming in here and i
got them set in my crab pot i'm a man of
the sea here i love it here
cool like that
i would like to say my way of life is
simple
but it seems like it's anything but
sometimes
[Music]
we're looking for our standing dead
roost trees today
we're gonna get as many trees we can if
the wind will allow
my name is joel jacko i'm from pedro bay
alaska
being an athabascan in the 21st century
is a lot about adapting
your tools may have changed but your
hunting ground is still the same
my ultimate goal in life is to be
self-reliant i'm a bush pilot
for the last 10 years i've been building
this house
i live here with my wife jacqueline and
my daughter ansley
i think it's important to try to pass
down traditions to ansley as much as we
can and i will teach her about the
athabascan way of life
so fred the bear he's kind of my
neighbor we see him every day he's
tracker's arch nemesis
so we're going to try to build a cast
fish and everything in there for the
winter
we're making an elevator to keep the
bears out because the bears are a big
problem around here
i'm gonna be really mad if fred eats our
fish it's a lot of work to go and get
them and then to have a bear eat them in
you know 10 minutes i don't like the
thought of that
it's pretty important to get this cast
days are getting shorter it's getting
colder we need to get done like the next
couple days
you ready
to bring ansley up with this kind of
lifestyle is important to me so she can
learn about her roots and be resourceful
i got a couple trees picked out for uh
the main posts on the on the cash the
wind and everything it's going to be a
little difficult getting the ball where
i want him
and if it doesn't want to go then
get out of the way
[Music]
jacqueline's from a family of sandy folk
she went from seattle to out here within
a month she adapted super quickly
a month into dating joel i used to go
out into the woods with him and he'd cut
trees down
i just thought you know
damn so hot
wood out here is a continual chore
it is non-stop you're just always
cutting wood and packing wood splitting
wood
non-stop
let's go home and build us a cash
i feel like my soul is connected to the
land because i am of the land
i'm a part of this environment
naturally for millennia
[Music]
wow there's a lot more ice on the river
today
not too long it'll be frozen
i know i'm so excited
we are in the middle yukon and koyakon
country at our fish camp
i grew up in my hungarian village of
eagle
our people have lived on this land for
millennia
so i was very much raised in that
culture in that way of life and i think
that being on the land is a strong part
of my identity
i eventually met my now husband jamie
joseph
and this is his family's native
allotment and his family's land
it's such a risky time of year to get
water
our family was blessed with the moose
but as the weather changes and it starts
to get colder there are other things
that we also need to be working on like
getting water getting wood the work is
never over
oh water dropped last night a lot more
ice you got that rope in your pocket
finale
okay let's be careful you guys it's
super dangerous
our only water source right now is
getting water from the yukon river which
is full of ice flow
all right going out
the ice isn't very stable yet the water
every day is dropping and there's air
pockets under the ice
there's been a lot of folks that have
fallen through unstable ice
and perished
careful
whoa did i rope off your overalls on
that little loop in the back i'd feel
better all right
come on
i don't want to go up that far
the only problem with being placed in
the back you're pulling on me i can't
turn around to get myself out and i'll
be like this
i'll end up head first in the water
if i fall yeah there you go that's
that's better
ah much better how about i just keep
this on you
funny funny can't lose my handsome hunka
hunk of burning love
i'm gonna reel you in
okay have me that bucket there
the river is powerful and unforgiving
and it demands respect
jamie and i and you know our lifetime of
experience
on this land and on the yukon river
we are each other's
anchor this rope represents the lab
right babe something like that all right
hurry up tonight
a youtube quiz is learned by observation
you've got to watch the weather watch
the people been passed down time and
memorial
[Music]
all right
head to the beach today
[Music]
my name is danielle passingall
my native name is takovami
i'm a siberian yupi i live in gamble
saint lawrence island with my family
my wife susan the passenger
my two boys
chris and chase
were actually closer to russia than
mainland alaska
bearing sea out there it's a way of life
for me and all the people in the village
we're subsistence hunters and that means
we go out and get marine mammals and
bring that food home
we don't just have a store that has
everything you want to eat
oh yeah winter is coming down on us and
now all the marine mammals that live up
there come down too with the
walls bearded seals
there's no farms out there to grow crops
no
cows no steak or anything
we eat what we catch
subsistence way of lifestyle
subsistence has been a very important
pro gamble we've been eating off the sea
for generations on end
i need to warm up another 15 degrees
yeah
right now it's a kind of too cold
temperature to go out well if you catch
a coil in a cold temperature
all the meat and monkto will freeze
instantly and be harder for butchery
i'm going to beat going a little bit
down this way
ammo and gas is expensive out here
got to make every shot count
here's all the games
got a beer to kill coming over
kind of out of range
oh
finger shot low on
no luck today
i need to provide uh food this week you
know uh maybe from uh ice fishing
whatever opportunity we can get
the importance of living sustainably is
really just preserving the land and the
way of life taking what you need no more
oh don't put the cash
why is it kind of cast
it's called a cash cause you
cashed your stuff in there
we're gonna put stuff in there so the
bear can't get it
that's where we're gonna make it way off
the ground we don't want them eating our
food um
this is basically what it looked like
and i need help
standing the uprights
up
makes sense
well i guess it will as we go yeah
i don't know if it makes sense to me yet
so getting ready for winter is a lot of
work and the bears being around all the
time is definitely cause we're concerned
because we are so close to the mountains
the weather happens to change super
quickly
you still gotta do what you got to do
and you're just going to be out there
with mother nature's throwing at you
okay
this is probably going to be the most
dangerous part
i think we're way off here
oh my gosh
okay
he needs to go back or this one you
could go forward
try to move that log back and if i say
run you better run
okay
yeah yeah
there you go
this is not lined up
ah
we're at a bad angle
can you just push it
yeah
oh my god
jacqueline's a good partner out here
it's always easier to get projects done
with two sets of hands i definitely
didn't know how to
do some of these things before i met
joel and we've learned together look at
that
that's what fred's gonna be doing to
this yeah give me some of that fish
yeah that looks much better
good job
we got half of what i wanted to do today
done
start again in the morning
huh
it helps clean up a little bit
now
[Music]
our way of living
every part of it is on the water
to see is something we pay close
attention to
hey um yeah
what's the plan for today well today
we're going to go up and pull the crab
pots
you and i will go on my skiff
and justin we're going his and are you
ready jeffy you got it down yep all
right i guess we're ready yeah let's
rock and roll
glenn is married to my niece marcella
he came up from california my name is
glenn dariel white jr
i moved up here
2005 and i have not left since
marvin shows me around out here shows me
hunting and fishing living out here and
what this life is about
i'm just showing you oh when you come on
your own you would have no problem buddy
because i'm going to show you the right
way
and as you learn you can find out the
shortcut
it's not much that i've learned is what
i've learned basic way of living out
here that's the knowledge that i carry
on
we're glad to be a part of what we see
makes it easier for him because i don't
want people to struggle out here
oh yeah we've got some ice build up
right there oh
that ice looks pretty uh pretty thick
over there
it's been cool since i set the crab pot
any ice or frost there's always a
concern i'm gonna go see if i could
break through that i got glenn here for
some weight in the bowel you calling me
fat
no it's just weird
we'll become an icebreaker so you just
follow me through there okay okay all
right sounds like a plan we'll give that
a shot because ty's
falling never rode the rice before have
you ever uh made it through the ice and
like got stuck on the other side
no i don't want to try not no no yeah i
don't want to try it
hold on there buddy we're coming up on
the ice i don't know what thick it is
but for five dollars
all right
a lot of ice yeah it is
seemed like a quarter mile of ice so i
figured i'd give it a little bit of gas
and sway my motor back and forth and
give us a little rocking movement and
keep the momentum going
you can't see the water move but you see
the ice just cracking it makes this
sound
it's breaking but if we go too much and
end up on it we're stuck out here
oh that's a chunk yeah it's got thicker
here
hope we make it
man
we made it through
just when you realize how small and
insignificant you really are yeah
all right ducky's ready hope we get crab
viva la icebreaker
in today's modern world being able to
bring my kids to
lands and use trails that have been used
for time immemorial it's just a powerful
powerful feeling
[Music]
thanks bud
that's good
my right-hand man so handsome
gathering water gathering wood those are
all like our first order of business
when we arrive at camp
how's it going
going all right looks good there's
another tree right here we could
probably buck up right here oh yeah i
need to cut that smaller it's kind of
long sounds good
as a kid growing up i always went out
with my dad and brother to cut firewood
i learned to run a saw sometime in my
teen years it's good work it warms you
twice three times four times cutting the
firewood
bucking it up
stacking it
chopping it
bringing it home
and then you get to put it in your stove
after you bring it in
keeps you healthy keeps you strong and
it's good hard work that makes you feel
alive
so if you guys want to grab the last
load of wood i'll
make a campfire and some tea for all of
us sound good sounds good
go team
we are just
nourished by the land it provides us a
lot of our basic needs
perfect
[Music]
the land provides us with their water
and our food
and also provides us with a lot of peace
like it's just a good feeling at the end
of the day after you've spent time on
the land
clean snow
wow water's already boiling
there's all kinds of medicines and teas
around us
our people call it gelatin
it's this little leaf tasty and has a
lot of medicinal
purposes you tired son
he worked hard today he wants to see the
nelly
good signs for sure
got water got plenty of firewood then we
got a moose we have everything we need
so i feel rich
different kind of cold out here
somebody from mainland
they think it'd be too cold to do
anything
just our
lifestyle helped us to heal who we are
today
yeah we're going to try to go out
fishing today
see if we can catch uh tom cotton smelt
winter is coming you know we've got to
stock up our food
hey
[Music]
i've been teaching my boys how to do
subsistence lifestyle hunting and
fishing who's going to catch one first
race
you know we take whatever opportunity we
can get
nice weather we're having today huh
beautiful
come on pin salmon
the water temperatures is warmer than
the air's temperature
you're on the island 200 miles off the
mainland alaska the weather changes
fairly quick you've got to be prepared
for that
wanna get ready yeah
get home before it gets worse
if it gets too hot out on us we won't
know where we're going
we might end up running into those
rivers that have really thin ice fall
into those and you'll never come back up
i pretty much experienced all the uh the
weather you can handle out here
you got to be very knowledgeable about
how to uh handle
it finally home
oh fish
tasty first
time to go uh turn the stove on warm up
the mindset of living out here and
living up the land
just beat into you to be resourceful
so the uprights were a little more
difficult than i thought they were gonna
be but i think at this stage it should
go a little faster
i think fred might be coming
you definitely got to be vigilant and
keep these bears out of stuff
that's why they're building the cash
so
[Music]
we kind of got a window in the weather
right now leaving a little blue sky show
on so try to get as much done as i can
right now
i don't even stand on right now this is
pretty awkward
[Music]
yeah
i'm glad jacqueline's not up here for
this uh this part
she would not be happy
exactly everything's more dangerous than
i need to be but i like to get stuff
done as quickly as possible
[Music]
all right screwing's done i'll start
building the walls and then the roof
after that
being in the woods man it feels great
especially when there's nobody around
it's just you
definitely gives you a sense of peace
happiness
accomplishment
around here you got to pay attention to
mother nature because it's just so
unpredictable and you just got to be
prepared for that
there
you see the buoy yeah right there
we made it through the ice
me marvin and justin we're all gonna
pull the crab pots
and hopefully it'll be loaded with some
king crab and we'll be able to eat
tonight
gotcha and just put it right to the
roller
okay just pull some flag
on this side jack dude
he's gonna go that way and wait for the
pot to come up okay
we pull apart one goes one direction
one stays above the pot
all right
prior to us using two skiff we would
pull it by hand that's how my dad done
it and um those days are over it's so
much easier we use two skips
you just watch him and then you can see
about 300 feet back that's when it'll
come up
300 feet 50 fathoms of line
the worst that could happen the line bus
and the pot just free falls
we've got to be getting pretty close
it's still just the line when the line
you could grab somebody but you just
don't want it to bust off
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
okay stop it
grab it
got her
okay however doing
oh we got some crap
we are dead lifting the crown pot right
over the side of the skiff oh hold it
grab my leg my leg okay there you go
oh my goodness
yeah
[Applause]
we got everybody we got a few
people got dinner oh yeah
one
two three cool like that well i see
three
in the store it's like a hundred dollars
for three legs out here we just go out
and get it it's worth the trip
because we got a few tanners didn't we
this is too small to keep sand this is
gonna be the future yeah future
we gotta give back take them all we'll
run out
we overcame
thank you there's a pleasure i don't get
to usually come out and get king crabs
last tour i took you could take these
orders so we get more huh sound good
thank you i got a big pot we'll just
cook them all together and be done with
them oh yeah sounds like a plant sounds
good guys we're off
like a herd of turtles
that's what you get here in hockey the
closeness the families the camaraderie
where i came from it's mind mind mind
take take take here people want to give
[Music]
wealth is not important to me in money
but i feel rich in
quality of life
i already fried up some tenderloin and
fat for the family and i got some
diced up backstrap here i'm gonna cook
with this rice
we're able to have some fresh meat and
not have to eat so much spam
this mousse
is a lot to us
winter's meat and it's healthy
culturally you know it's our soul food
it's our medicine so just such a
blessing
and that's how i have healthy strong
kids is having good
healthy organic protein
i know what's in this meat and it's
hard to be oh i'm always so proud when i
have a rhyme
as a mom especially as a native mom
there's so much that i have to know and
learn so i can pass it down to my
children traditional knowledge and
skills and values all those things are
really important to pass down
that fact
kids are so much help like and i didn't
have to pack any meat it's just so crazy
because like when they were small
i was packing all the meat and now it's
reversed
so thankful
i can't stop i'm going to hurt myself
sure i'll help
this village has been hunting off of the
bearing sea land for thousands of years
i'd like to be happy to keep that going
[Music]
finally got a little bit of a break of
good weather here it's a good window for
fishing
it's going to be a
good opportunity today
hey
first of all
this is what we get smelt and uh top
cards my tank salmon huh
they're down there
got a couple of nibbles
oh man
look like you got the hot hole today
hey
i still got nothing
chase
he's my younger boy you know he
wants to follow the footsteps of chris
and you know
it's just a lot of fun watching the boys
grow up to be who they are today now
i don't know why they don't want to bite
my hook
maybe use his hole
oh man
almost
gonna call you all moose
when you find the spot from fish head
you know there'll be fish biting every
minute or two you'll pull them right out
of the hole one after the other
you just gotta be patient with me
hey you got another one
what the hell is going on
whatever fish i catch out here is gonna
be a canned salmon
come on bowie what's going on i have no
clue what's going on geez gotta work for
it come
all right
puppy finally got a fish
kang salmon
[Laughter]
we're lucky to be on the island where we
can catch almost everything out here
from fish to birds to a big game
it's just right there on the island
something very beautiful about it
you guys got enough here
get ready
race for the last fish
[Music]
i want
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
subsistence lifestyle i learned from my
father anderson passenger and i teach it
to my boys too and some days you know
they'll teach it to their own kids
[Music]
21 i got 21.
[Music]
it's a blessing to catch your food you
know it's a blessing to share your food
at the same time
can't wait to eat tonight
so we'll get it on a hard steam and then
we'll do um 20 minutes
i am willing to teach this native way of
living in the subsisting and it's
all been brought down from my parents
and i feel very fortunate to pass that
on to someone else of different
cultures
there you go
it cools them off fast and
the meat tightens up and it pulls off
the shell
oh
here's dinner
it was a very good day you guys yes
put a little bit of treasure through the
ice we made it and there you go
thank you wonk
you tell the kids i'll stop by sometimes
later on this evening
so this is my last wall i'm gonna finish
uh
finish this up cut the doorway out and
then i'll pretty much be done
[Music]
super excited to show jacqueline last
thing she saw i think was just the
decking now we have a whole building
living out here it's kind of like a
different way of life and it makes you a
little more self-reliant i think it's
important to pass these skills on to my
daughter ansley and even to jacqueline
hi honey hey give me one minute i'll cut
the door out and then i'll be done it
looks amazing
the cash is important for us to have
this winter relieves a lot of stress
knowing that the bears aren't going to
be able to get into our cache
yeah
can i come up there with you yeah come
on up i think this way life is important
it's ansel angel's roots and heritage
and you know people aren't really
relying on what's around them anymore
you have my coat no
yen i can't believe it's done we've like
i know but there's so much
if fred can get in here he deserves to
eat the fish
this is a piece that i found in the
hills back here when i was out hunting
one day
and diamond willow is the type of willow
we have up here in alaska has a really
beautiful look dark color and the light
color of the grain of wood and then
these diamonds that are naturally formed
it's just really special
you don't see logs this big or with this
beautiful development of diamonds like
this is a really unique piece so
i'll work on it for a while and
just steadily because it's such a huge
piece
there's so much beauty on this land
and today it warmed up really nice it's
only like zero
so it's a good day to work on this when
it's warm out
i know that i could adapt and live and
be happy in hawaii for instance but the
thing that keeps me here is i'm
indigenous to this land and i have a
responsibility
to our people so our people can continue
our way of life and thrive
years ago when i was probably just a
baby my grandpa carved a diamond willow
cane
you know it's just something that our
people have done through the generations
you know one of the things that i've
always reiterated to my children is to
remember who we are
our people have lived here for millennia
we've survived racism genocide
poverty and
violence and overcome a lot and there's
still a lot more work to be done
we don't need to do soul searching
we know who we are
where we come from
and where we belong
[Music]
you